while at home I was watching Futurama
and during the episode the characters
laying on an alien world that had three
sons and left me wondering what would
happen if there was a second or third
star in our solar system either in orbit
around our Sun or fighting with it to
become the center of the solar system
thank you and thanks for the show mmm so
here's the problem yeah if you start
throwing extra Suns in the middle of
your star system depends on how far away
your planetary orbit is mm-hmm
if you're not far enough away from all
of them mm-hmm listen it's late let's
say is a triple star system do one up on
that what they showed in Star Wars so
let's have a triple star system if
you're not really far away from all
three what's considered really far like
Jupiter much farther than any one of
them are from each other okay so it's a
relative statement so you want to be far
enough away so that all three stars feel
like one source of gravity to you I see
if you're too close and one is over to
the left and one is over to the right
your gravitational allegiance becomes
constantly compromised who am i orbiting
today oh it's right star not that one
and you become really close to one star
and far from another your climate would
be all to hell because you wouldn't
sustain a stable temperature environment
and we you can do models on a computer
to show what happens to these orbits and
most of them are unstable right the star
light a fault a planet will have fall
into a star or be ejected from the star
system altogether so but it would be
fine if you simply were so far away that
they felt like one they felt like one
and they did it right in star wars where
they have a double sunset if you
remember that scene those were far
enough away from the planet yeah the
planet is really only seeing one sort of
collective you have that isn't it yeah
and so that's the problem that you have
here but otherwise it'd be really cool
you'll also be cool if the stars wear
different colors and then you have a
yeah it's one star set the color of your
sky would change